comment les prélèvements fiscaux et les
bénéfices public tu as fait les
contribuables tout au long de leur vie
une étude de l'université de sherbrooke
s'est penché sur la question pour en
parler ce soir luc godbout professeur
titulaire de la chaire de recherche en
fiscalité et en finances publiques
bonsoir bonsoir de l'université de
sherbrooke vous avez bâti une étude nous
t'y en quelque sorte pour regarder tout
ce qu'on paie tout ce qu'on reçoit tout
au cours d'une vie qu'est ce que vous
avez voulu mettre de l'avant avec sa
souvent à l'achat on se fait on se fait
dire quand vous faites votre bilan
fiscalité vous mettez un gros focus sur
le fait que les poids le poids de la
fiscalité est important au québec mais
très peu sur le fait des services
publics qu'on reçoit en échange alors et
et à d'autres occasions on fait des
études et on monte pour un couple que
les impôts sont plus importants que les
bénéfices reçu alors qu'elle est inverse
on fait la même
le mend kotick m'ont fait pour un couple
de retraités on voit que les services
publics sont plus importants que les
impôts payés mais il faut pas oublier
que le couple de retraités a déjà été un
coup de deux travaillant dans le passé
et donc de ce que ça nous permet de
faire c'est de suivre un contribuable
tout sa vie durant de sa majorité
jusqu'à son décès avec des hypothèses on
essaie d'avoir le contribuable le plus
représentatif ou le plus typique d'un
québécois vous donne québécois c'est
très utile parce que ça nous met toute
une vie en contexte et donc vous avez
considérer certaines choses on va
regarder ça ce que vous considérez dans
l'outil qui permet donc de voir combien
on a contribué combien on a reçu au fil
du temps alors du côté des prélèvements
ce qu'on considère comme prélèvements
considère impôt sur le revenu
ce soit de ottawa ou du québec tps tvq
les taxes et les cotisations sociales
assurance emploi assurances québécois
parents l'assurance parentale ainsi que
régime des rentes du québec
on n'a pas considéré par exemple l'impôt
foncier
parce qu'on est au fond aussi il aurait
fallu poser des hypothèses selon qu'on
habite en au saguenay où qu'on habite à
montréal des hypothèses donc on reste
vraiment le cas le plus typique possible
du côté des services publics
on rentre notamment s'il ya des enfants
des garderies l'éducation primaire
secondaire collégial universitaire celio
lieu et la santé et l'assurance
médicaments ce côté des services publics
et du côté des prestations et là c'est
vraiment l'échec en espère si vous avez
des enfants des allocations familiales
si vous êtes des retraités c'est l'échec
penser en sécurité de la vieillesse
d'ottawa régime des rentes du québec à
québec et des chèques de soutien de
revenus de type crédit soit dalit et
crédits de tps et des allemands qui y
ont été considérés en termes de
prestations reçues et donc pour
l'exercice d'aujourd'hui un kotick
oui une femme oui qui va prendre sa
retraite à 60 ans c'est ça donc on a une
femme qui fait des études collégiales
qui est embauché par la fonction
publique active de technicienne elle
commence à travailler à 21 ans elle
prend sa retraite à 60 ans mais
demandent ces chefs du régime des rentes
du québec à 65 ans et elle décède à 81
70 donc c'est l'école de plus typique on
a là un salaire là qui équivaut à
seillans 33 et 50 3000 selon le début et
la fin de sa carrière donc c'est assez
typique de la société québécoise et lola
suisse selon trois récits de vie ici on
va présenter deux mais d'abord elle
reste célibataire toute sa vie le
deuxième scénario c'est les célibataires
à 25 à 27 ans il commence à vivre en
couple elle a un enfant 29 ans elle un
deuxième enfant à 31 ans et elle vit en
couple toute sa vie son mari décède
avant elle et elle décède à 81 certain
que le troisième scénario qui serait
monoparentales parfaitement réalisé avec
les deux régions et qu'on a retenu les
deux récits de vie personnes seules et
couples avec deux enfants
donc ce qui était en route chez les
prélèvements et les prélèvements de
toute nature en bleu c'est nos services
publics et anvers et les prestations les
chèques versés par l'état
donc si on est célibataire on s'aperçoit
que à part les premières années où on
est aux études ou là on a des services
publics ses dépendances
la dame et au cg c'est soit on part de
20 ans on est rendus jusqu'à 75 ans très
sensible alors que lorsqu'elle commence
à travailler à 21 ans s'aperçoit
rapidement que les impôts exceed durant
la vie active les services publics reçus
ou les prêts les prestations elle a
pratiquement pas de prestations mais
dans le cas ici pour comprendre que les
célibataires et donc pas de la location
pour enfants par exemple et par la suite
lorsqu'elle prend sa retraite c'est
essentiellement régime des rentes et
pension de sécurité de la vieillesse les
éléments en banque et là on voit que en
fin de vie lorsqu'elle est inactive les
services publics qui comprennent la
santé et les le rrq les prestations
excède les impôts payés et donc on voit
que
au début on paye plus et à la fin on
reçoit plus que ce qu'on fait ça c'est
la ligne du zéro donc c'est ce qu'on
paie oui et c'est ce qu'on reçoit qui
est en haut et on voit vraiment que vers
la fin de la vie on reçoit beaucoup
alors que dans le cas d'un couple avec
deux enfants la des bénéfices et des
prestations il y en a pas mal à
satisfaire l'on voit que les premières
années ou lorsqu'elle est aussi au
collège c'est la même chose et les
dernières années lorsqu'elle est rendue
oeuvre parce que son mari après décédé
s'adonne sensiblement la même chose mais
entre les deux lorsqu elle forme un
couple lorsque les enfants arrivent on
s'aperçoit que les impôts sont plus
important parce que de revenus dans le
coup plutôt qu'un seul et que lorsque
des enfants
arrivée du premier enfant voyez les
grands bâtons versé de régime québécois
d'assurance parentale des forts
bénéfices des fois prestation est ici on
voit que les services publics sont plus
important parce que les enfants vont à
la garderie par le souhaitent ils vont à
l'école il ya quatre personnes ici qui
bénéficie de soins de santé au lieu
d'une seule
donc on voit que le portrait
complètement différent et encore une
fois rendu à la retraite mais là on voit
que les prestations de des deux
conjoints sont nettement plus
importantes avec les seuls les services
publics que les impôts qui sont payés
est ce que quand je regarde ça est ce
que je comprends qu'on reçoit autant
peut-être même plus que ce qu'on donne
que ce qui nous est prélevé alors d'une
vie sur la base de ce qu'on a considéré
pour une personne seule grosso modo si
on vise qu'à 85 ans c'est le point où on
est payé autant que ce qu'on a reçu donc
c'est sûr que si on décède avant 85,1 on
va en avoir payé plus que ce qu'on va en
avoir reçu puis si on survit à 85 ans on
va toujours avoir des prestations
additionnelles et qui vont accéder les
impôts payés ce serait pour une personne
c'est à peu près ça pour un couple
encore une fois on en a plus
mais ça arrive plus tôt que ça arrive
autour de la mi mai autour de milieu des
années 60 sous de ton âge 70 ans ou là
tu vas avoir plus de bénéfices que ce
que tu vas avoir payé en prélèvement
cela dit ça c'est pour un coach pour la
personne seule est fait à peu près 50
milles à la fin de sa carrière et pour
un couple on va jusqu à peu près 120
milles de revenu familial
si on faisait le même exercice avec une
personne seule qui gagnent 4 100 1000
par année
clairement les impôts serait plus
important que les prestations reçues sur
un cycle de vie
très intéressant merci beaucoup le
godbout y'a pas toi si bien